let's talk of Madonna drinking wine with
a spoon the word hashtag detox has 13
million users on Instagram the words
paleo quito and macrobiotic are creeping
in some otherwise normal conversations
and dry no longer has anything to do
with the weather
it can only be January a month so
miserable there's nothing to lose by
turning to self-improvement
I'm totally guilty of buying into the
seasonal faddish ness right now I am on
a green juice cleanse contributing my
pennies quite a lot of them actually to
the UK's twenty billion pound diet and
wellness industry we're not short of
celeb encouragement either from Beyonce
calling for fans to join her in the
January the Gwyneth Paltrow's endless
stream of it has to be said
scientifically challenged advice the
fact is the science around detoxes
cleanses and sticking Jade eggs where
the Sun doesn't shine sorry Queenie is
pretty thin on the ground and we should
all be mindful of extreme regimes that
encourage eating disorders and real
health risks but a lot of us are just
trying to do something mindful with our
diets to rebalance after a season of
excess reintroducing a bit of discipline
and restoring good habits surely that is
what the doctor ordered well first thing
I would say a four is no diets please
wear garnet garnet culture does not
believe in diet
we believe in the ass absolutely not
yeah and I've got a funny story for you
so I'm speaking of a gallery I do it
every year I'm vegan reor began Ria's as
therefore just for the month just a
month so you got vegan for the month
which is what jay-z and beyonce is
saying and and so a few years ago my
agent called me up and said oh are you
still vegan I said oh why she said well
we've had an offer come through and but
it requires you to be vegan so I got the
offer through and I was like oh I'm
still be
they meant that I needed sort of three
months into it I'm still vegan anyway
they then start looking at my social
media because I was supposed to start
posting about this thing and they're
like we've been looking at doing social
media we've seen her Christmas pictures
it doesn't seem she's a vegetarian
needless to say that India um no I think
you enjoy the vegan explain I do it
every year I do just for a month um yeah
I love it I think there's nothing wrong
with it
it's healthy clear to our I think it's
just like she said it shows discipline
you feel better you have more energy
your skin improves as a result I
wouldn't do it all the time and I think
at the end of day it's about control
with these things as opposed to becoming
obsessed but there's no harm in it do
you feel good doing it I feel great well
you know it's more a little bit more of
your personal case 20 billion pounds you
say I wish I was perfect how much is it
costing you this special diet it's not a
diet
yes it's not cheap well that's not
answering the patient how much is this
ratio question you know okay if the
grand is too much then it's fine 300
pounds okay five days they deliver my
cold-pressed you know every morning I do
what you do stream juices currently the
first one of the day is like a turmeric
and ginger and linseed alexia and then
like green juice it's gonna try but you
won't you do all this I'm gonna put all
vegans into room 101 absolutely because
there's nothing worse than someone
coming to lunch and then you're cooking
it and then they say oh actually I'm a
vegan I said just bring your own food
but I do stop I have stopped drinking
for January I have been on almost all
these fetish diets you
no no that's what we're about Wow look
we're recommending up yeah you're quite
hot Oh Sonia only woman can do that
talking spend a week where I know when I
do it the end of a week I hate going you
don't eat all sorts of things for that
week you feel much better
but the idea that you're gonna do it for
life I don't think of anything worse
yeah well I'd say do you think it's not
particularly you have children's well
isn't it easier just to live healthy
lifestyles and then you wouldn't feel a
need to do these three to five well I
think a healthy lifestyle is common
sense basically it's you're not going to
be drinking your body weight in alcohol
you're not gonna be in a load of crap
and rubbish and process and all I see
you every day we are all you not me I'm
not put myself in this bracket but you
la are all falling for the marketeers
dream no yes it's 300 quid I will come
to your house yeah I will turn up in a
penny you feel much better it's money
well so why do you feel bad a lot of it
is psychological I think it's you saying
to yourself this week I'm gonna be more
mindful I'm gonna be discipline time
it's not business as usual it's probably
the psychological effect of just
deciding to do so I have a green juice
every day at the moment and I make it
for myself
I don't change any of my other habits
just incorporate a green juice
chemically diet did you do no not at all
not at all what did I do
I've got a bicycle I started cycling and
I'm not back on the amount of drink that
I was drinking although that's slightly
crept back up again and I stopped eating
really poor food so I didn't have I used
to have on takeaways cuz I'm a single
blow so I used to just ring up and get
the Indian restaurant or the Chinese
restaurant in all seriousness you know
picking up on your debate Michelle and
what I was discussing now we do have to
look at obesity and we do have to look
at how we get children eating in a more
healthy way early and I've got a great
clip here by dr. William verge GP
talking about what obesity actually does
to the body what happens is in cells of
fat cells particularly the ones in a
tummy they create this inflammation this
inflammation starts to attack the brain
it starts to attack arteries and that
leads to diabetes dementia even and
depression anxiety cardiovascular
disease all those conditions that we get
all start off in children we need to
start this stuff early that's really
important and also I do want to
introduce a kind of class money aspect
cause yeah I mean I am embarrassed how
much I spend on my juicer and it's going
to be replaced as a holiday it may be
that I would have gone on but it is
expensive if you want to do any of these
wellness Ramah keto diet you're eating
the high fat grass-fed meat so for
chicken breasts and some broccoli to eat
junk and that is my issue we always talk
about tackling sugar and taxing fat I
would rather we subsidize healthy food
so that it's more accessible cheaper to
eat vegetables just a lot of weight he
knows and that's not because of Jeremy
Corbyn being the leader it's amazing
this is my daily
cup of coffee usually I'll skip food for
breakfast and I just have either a
little bit of butter or what they call
MCT oil in my coffee and for me when I
first started doing it it took away the
sugar cravings and this just sort of
gets me through to lunchtime without
being particularly hungry in the morning
this is the this could be the high point
what most people who go on these things
lose might put your back up now I do but
he lives on that Apple which I wouldn't
don't take this as dietary